feature selection
in machine learning my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.
get certified get ahead today we're
going to look at what's in it for you
the need for feature selection what is
feature selection
feature selection methods feature
selection
statistics so the need for feature
selection
to train a model we collect huge
quantities of data to help the machine
learn better
consider a table which contains
information on old cars
the model decides which cars must be
crushed for spare parts
and when we talk about huge quantities
of data there they save everything from
people's favorite cat pictures
to and you can imagine there's so much
data out there
even in a company they'll save all these
little pieces of information about
people and companies and corporations
you need some way to sort through
because if you try to run your models on
all of it
you'll end up with these very clunky
models and they might have
issues which we'll talk about later but
in this case we're talking about cars
and crushing but not all this data will
be useful to us
some classes or part of the data may not
contribute much to our model and can be
dropped
and you can see right here we have who
was the owner of the car
in our data a car will not be crushed
based on its previous owner
so yeah that's kind of a clear cut you
can see that why would i care who owned
the car before once it's in the junkyard
and we're
crushing the cars we're not going to
really care about that
so here we have dropped the owner column
as it does not contribute to the model
having too much unnecessary data can
cause the model to be slow
the model may also learn from this
irrelevant data and be inaccurate
so feature selection is a process of
reducing the
input variable to your model by using
only relevant data
and getting rid of the noise in the data
consider the database given below
a library wants to donate some old books
to make place in their shells for new
books
we want to train a model to automate
this task
in this case the color of the book does
not matter and keeping it can cause a
model to learn to donate books based on
color
we can remove this as a feature using
feature selection we can optimize our
model in several ways
and so the number one is to prevent
learning from noise and overfitting
that's actually the huge one because we
we don't want it to give us the wrong
prediction
and that means also improved accuracy
so instead of giving us a wrong
prediction we also want it to be as
close to the right
answer as we can get and we want to
reduce the training time
it's an exponential growth in some of
these models so the each feature you add
in increases that much
more training time we talk about feature
selection methods
uh we put together a nice little flow
chart that shows the various methods
used for feature selection
and you have your basic feature
selection and then there is supervised
and unsupervised under supervised
there's intrinsic wrapper method
filter method so we talk about
unsupervised feature selection
refers to the method which does not need
the output label class for feature
selection
and that was uh you can see here under
super unsupervised we don't have
i mean that's really a growing market
right now
unsupervised learning and so feature
selection is the same thing
supervised feature selection refers to
the method which uses the output label
class for the feature selection
and if you remember we looked at three
different
we have intrinsic wrapper and filter
method so we're going to start with the
filter method on this
now remember we know what the output is
so we're going to be looking at that
output to see how well
it's doing versus the features in this
method
features are dropped based on their
relation to the output or how
they are correlating to the output
you can see here we have a set of
features selecting best feature learning
algorithm and then performance
and so we want to find out which feature
correlates to the performance on the
output
consider the example of book classifier
here we drop the color column based on
simple deduction
and that kind of sums it up in the in a
nutshell as we want to filter out things
that clearly do not go with what we're
looking for
we look at the wrapper method in the
wrapper method
we split our data into subsets and train
a model using this
based on the output of the model we add
and subtract features and train the
model again
and you can see here in the wrapper
method we have a set of features
we generate a subset we run it through
the algorithm and we see how
each one of those subset of features
performs
consider the book data set by using the
wrapper method
we would use a subset of different
features to train the machine and adjust
the subset according to the output
and so you can see here let's say we
take a name a number of times
red and we run just those and we look at
the output
and if we looked at him with all four
inputs and look at the output
we'd see quite a different variation in
there and we might say you know what
condition of the book and color
really doesn't affect what we're looking
for and you can see here we've run it on
condition of the book and color
depending on the output of the model we
will choose our final set of features
these features will give us the best
result for our model
and it might come up that the name
number of times red is probably pretty
important
the intrinsic method this method
combines the qualities of both filter
and wrapper method to create the best
subset the model will train and check
the accuracy of different subsets and
select the best among them
we kind of looked at a little overview
of some of the stuff some of the common
feature selection algorithms
based on which method they belong to are
given below
and you'll see is primarily under
supervised there's not like i said a lot
of unsupervised methods
and the ones that are usually used these
methods
and finds a way to create a supervised
connection between the data and we talk
about supervised
methods we have our filter method which
we talked about and it uses like the
pearson's coefficient
t squared anova coefficient those are
all under the filter method
and in the wrapper method recursive
feature elimination so remember we're
choosing a subset
and we want to go through there and look
at each one so you're just doing a lot
of loops or recursive
calculations to see which one works best
and which ones don't have an impact on
the output
and there's a lot of genetic algorithms
to go with this too on the wrapper
method and how they evaluate it
and with the intrinsic method there's
the two main ones we're looking at is
the lasso regularization
the lasso algorithms are basically your
standard
regression model so it's finding out how
these
different methods fit together and which
ones have the best
add together to have the least amount of
error the other
one used in the intrinsic method is the
decision tree it says hey if this one is
this one produces this result this one
produces this result
yes no which way do we go based on the
input and the output variables we can
choose our feature selection model
so you have your numeric input coming in
you have a numeric output
if you use the pearson's correlation
coefficient or spearman's rank
coefficient
you can then select what features you're
going to feed into
that specific model and you maybe have a
numerical input and a categorical input
so we're going to be looking more at a
nova correlation coefficient or kindle's
rank
coefficient and if you have a core
categorical input and a numerical output
we might be looking at anova correlation
coefficient in kindle's rank coefficient
so based on the input and the output
variables we can choose our feature
selection
model and you can see we have
categorical to categorical
we might be looking at the chi-squared
test
contingency tables and mutual
information
let's go and take a look and see in the
python code what we're talking about
here
and i'm going to go ahead and use for my
ide the jupiter
notebook in the and i always launch it
out of anaconda on here
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
create a new python 3 module
and we'll call it uh
feature select
and since we're in python we're going to
be working
mainly with your numpy your pandas your
matplot library
so we have our number array our data
frame setup which goes with the number
array the numpy the pandas data frame
and then we want to go ahead and graph
everything so we're going to import
these three modules
and then we put together some data
we're going to read this in it's kobe
bryant i guess he's a basketball player
our guys in the back we have a number of
them guys
both we have a lot of men and women so
it's probably a misnomer
our team in the back they have a some of
them have a liking for
basketball and they know who kobe bryant
is and they want to learn a little bit
more about kobe bryant what's going in
for what
whatever is going on with his game in
basketball so we're going to take a look
at him
and once we import the data we can see
what columns are available
original features count so we can see
how many features there are
the length of it we'll actually have a
list of them and then print just
the data head the top five rows and so
when we do this
we can see from the csv file we have
25 original features our original
features are your action type combine
shot type game event id and so forth
there's a lot of features in here that
they're
recorded on all of his shots this is we
talk about like a massive amount of data
i mean people are sitting there and they
record all this stuff
and they import this stuff for different
reasons but depending on what we want to
look at
do we really want all those features
maybe the question
we're going to ask is what's the chance
of him making any one
specific shot
in right from the beginning we can look
at the some of these
things and say team name uh team name
probably
i don't know maybe it does matter
because the other team might be really
good at defense
uh game date maybe we don't really want
to look at the game date
team id definitely not of importance in
any of this
so we look at this we have 25 features
and some of these features just
really don't matter to us we also have
location x location
y latitude and longitude i'm guessing
that's the same data we've actually
imported the the very similar data maybe
they're slightly zoned differently
but as far as our program we don't want
to repeat data
some of the models when you repeat data
into them and this is true for most
models
create a huge bias they weigh that data
over other data
so just at a glance these are the things
we're looking at we want to find out
well how do we get this
these features down and get rid of this
bias and all these extraneous features
that we don't really want to
spend time running our models on and
programming on
and as i pointed out there's a location
x a location y
latitude and longitude let's take a look
at that and see what we're looking at
here
we'll go ahead and create a plot of
these
and we'll just plot we'll do a scatter
plot of location x and location y
and then we'll do a scatter plot
of data lawn data lat which is probably
longitude and latitude
and the scatter plot let's go ahead and
actually put a little title here
location and scatter on there we'll just
go ahead and plot these
and when you look at this coming in
these two graphs are pretty identical
except they're flipped
and so when we look at the location from
which they're shooting from
they're probably the same and at this
point we can say okay we can get rid of
one of these sets of datas we don't need
both x and y
and latitude and longitude because it's
the same data coming in and
as we look at this particular data the
latitude longitude
we might also ask does it really make a
difference
which side of the chord you're on
whether you're on the left side or the
right side
and so we might go ahead and explore
instead of looking at this
as x y we might look at it as a distance
and an angle
and we can easily compute that and you
can see we can create our data distance
equals location x plus the location y
squared standard euclidean geometry or
triangular geometry hypotenuse squared
equals the
each side squared
and then once we've done that
we can also compute the angle so the
data angle is based on the arc tangent
uh and so forth on here so this is all
this is we're just going to compute the
angle here
and then set that up pi over 2 to get
our angle
and we'll go ahead and run that and
you'll see some errors run
come up and that's because when we took
slices over here
we took a slice of a slice
there's ways to fix that but it's really
not important for this example
so if you do see that you want to start
looking up here for
um instead of data location x of uh
not location x0 this would be like
i believe the term is ilo dot ilocation
if this was
yeah this is in pandas uh so there's
different things in there but for this
it doesn't really matter
these are just warnings that's all they
are and then let's combine our remaining
minutes and seconds column into one
there's another one so if you remember
up here we're trying to get rid of these
columns
do we really need let me see if i can
find it on here
there we go there's our minutes
remaining
and then they had what was it it was
minus remaining and seconds column so
there's also a seconds column on here
let me see if i can find that one this
is where it really gets kind of crazy
because
here's our seconds remaining so you can
see that here's our minutes remaining
this gets crazy when you're looking at
hundreds of these features
and you can see that if if i'm going to
say
write a model that's going to predict a
lot of this and i want it to run
in this case it's a basketball and how
good his shots are
as the data comes in let's say i want to
have it run on your phone
if i'm running it across hundreds of
features it's going to just hang up on
your phone where if i can get it down to
just a handful we'll actually be able to
come in here and run it
on a smaller device and not use up as
much memory
or processing power so we'll go ahead
and take data remaining time here
and data minutes remaining times 60 plus
data seconds remaining so we're just
going to combine those
and we'll go ahead and reprint our data
so we can see what we got
um coming across we have our action type
combined and this is
we do this a lot uh we want to take a
look at
oops i got so so zoomed in let me see if
i can zoom out just a little
bit there we go
boom all right so we come up here you
can see that we now have our distance
our angle
remaining time which is now just a
number uh that computes both the minutes
and seconds together
and we still have we've we've been
adding columns i thought you said we're
supposed to subtract columns right
um we're going to delete the obsolete
columns when we get to them
so we're just filtering out and this is
the filter method we're just filtering
through the things
that we really don't need
and next let's go ahead and explore team
id
and team name let me just go ahead and
run that
and if you look at this we have los
angeles lakers and then they have the
team id here and they're unique there's
not that's not really
anything that's going to come up because
that's
this particular athletes
works for that team so it's the same on
every line so there's another thing we
can filter out on there
team id and tname is just useless the
whole column contains only one value
each
and it's pretty much useless let's go
ahead and take a look at match up
an opponent that's an interesting one
and we see here that
we have the lal versus por
and the opponent is por and ind
again here's a lot of duplicate
information
so this basically contains the same
information
on here again we're filtering all this
stuff out and
this is because we're only looking at
one athlete and this might change if
you're looking at multiple athletes that
kind of thing now
these are easy to see but we might have
something that looks more like this
we might have something where we're
looking at the distance which we
computed
and the shot distance are they the same
thing
and what we can do is we can plot that
and plot them against each other on here
and we see it just draws a nice straight
line and so
again we're looking at the same
information
so again we're repeating stuff and we
really don't want to be running our
model
on repeat information on here
so again it contains the same
information so now let's look at the
shot zone area shot zone basic
shot zone range so now we're looking at
the
zones and what does that mean and we'll
go ahead and and do this also in a
scatter plot
in this case we're going to just create
three of these side by side so we're
going to create
our plot figure side 20 by 10
and then we're going to define our
scatter plot by category feature
and we're going to do each one set up on
here give it a slightly different color
and so our shot zone area is going to be
plot
subplot 131 scatter three one is how
that's read by the way
meaning that it's number one
um we have three across and this is the
first one
down so one one one our scatter plot by
category is going to be the shot zone
area
we're going to plot that and then we're
going to do the
shot zone basic and then the shot zone
range and you just push them through our
definition so each of those
areas go through and you'll see one
three one one three two one three three
again it's a one by three setup and then
it's just a place on each one
and so we look at this we can see that
these shots
uh they map out the same so it's very
again redundant information that should
be intuitive
um when we're looking at this in this
color graphs
it kind of helps you start looking at
something you it's very intuitive like
this is
and you start to realize that some of
the stuff
you'll be looking for in data you might
not understand
and you'll see these circular patterns
where they match or they mostly match
and you start to realize when you're
looking at these that they're
repetitive data and then you want to
explore them more closely depending on
what domain you're working in
so we we look at these we look at them
and they look just like the regions of
the court
but we already have stored this
information in angle and distance
columns
so we've seen this image before we go
back up here
and here's our the similar image
and repeating that image is down here
and so let's go ahead and drop some of
this in
this stuff so now let's drop all the
useless columns
and we can drop the shot id team id team
name
shot zone area shot zone range shot zone
basic
the match up the longitude and latitude
because we're putting that into distance
seconds remaining minutes remaining
because we combine that into one column
shot distance because we have just
distance on there
location x location y the game event id
game id all this stuff is just being
dropped on here and we'll just go ahead
and loop through our drops
and this is a nice way of doing this
because as you're playing with this
um this kind of data putting your list
into
one setup helps because then you're just
writing it
through an iteration and you can come
back and change it
you might be playing with different
models and do this with models you might
be looking at all kinds of different
things that you can drop and add in
as you test these out and again we're
working in the filter
method so this is a lot of human
interaction with the data
and it takes a lot of critical thinking
to look at this stuff and say what
matches and what doesn't
and so we look at the remaining features
let me go ahead and just run this
the original to the new count we had 25
features
now we have 11 features you can see that
right there
we just circle that there's our 25 and
there's uh old
new now we're down to 11. so we've cut
it down to less than
half and you can just see
the actual different information on here
and the remaining time
at this point we filtered it through and
then we'd move into the next process
which would be to run our model on this
and maybe we would drop
some of the features and see if it runs
better or worse and what happens
that's kind of would be the next step on
there versus the filter setup and that
would be one of the other setups
depending on which algorithm you use
so that wraps up our demo on filter
the feature selection and going through
and seeing how these different features
are being repeated in this particular in
a basketball
setup there's luck i said there's a lot
of other methods on there but the filter
one is really good because that's where
you usually start you want to have your
own visual and try to understand
how it works thank you for joining us
for simply learn
that's www.simplylearn.com get certified
get ahead
for more information please visit
www.simple
you can also post information on the
youtube below and we will reply to that
if you want a copy of the data we use
for this you can also request that from
there
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here